When you visit a refugee camp full of Muslims, you don't expect to get into a lot of conversations about pigs, but that's what happened to me. This is about a month ago. I'd barely been in the refugee camp a few hours before people started telling me stories.
当你去访问一个到处都是穆斯林的难民营时，你不会指望进行很多关于猪的谈话，但这确实发生在我身上。这大概是一个月前的事了。我到难民营还没几个小时，人们就开始跟我讲故事了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
We've seen the pig with our own eyes. We've seen the boar. We've taken pictures of videos of it, videos of it.
我们亲眼见过那头猪。我们见过那头野猪。我们拍过它的照片和视频。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
We've taken a selfie with it. Yeah.
我们和它拍了张自拍。没错。
Bassam and Farhad are 19. That's an interpreter, by the way, speaking English. This  is a refugee camp in Greece called Ritsona, about an hour from Athens. It was thrown together in March by the government on an old air force base. Very quickly, they set up tents for 700 people, brought in a few dozen port-a-potties, designated an old helicopter pad as the soccer field. But it's the middle of the woods, so snakes get in the tents, and at night, wild boars do roam around. Everybody's attitude about the boars was like, seriously? We escaped a war, risked dying on these tiny boats, and now we come here and this?
巴萨姆和法哈德今年 19 岁。顺便说一下，刚才说话的是口译员，说的是英语。这是一个位于希腊的难民营，名叫里特索纳，距离雅典大约一小时路程。今年 3 月，政府在一个旧空军基地匆忙建起了这个营地。他们很快为 700 人搭起了帐篷，运来了几十个移动厕所，并将一个旧直升机停机坪指定为足球场。但它位于树林中央，所以蛇会钻进帐篷，晚上还有野猪出没。每个人对这些野猪的态度都是：真的吗？我们逃离了战争，冒着生命危险乘坐这些小船，现在来到这里却遇到这种事？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It is a huge boar. It's basically as big as we are. It's this big.
那是一头巨大的野猪。基本上和我们一样大。有这么大。
OK, so this is a video. Oh look. There it is.
好的，这是一个视频。哦，看。它在那儿。
Yes.
是的。
The boars especially hang out near the toilets, and they are really big and frightening. And some people just hold it in all night rather than go. Other people, they're taking action.
野猪特别喜欢在厕所附近游荡，它们真的很大而且很吓人。有些人宁愿憋一整晚也不愿去上厕所。其他人则采取了行动。
Over there. You see? This is a handmade trap.
就在那边。看见了吗？这是一个手工制作的陷阱。
Mimi Karmiri was the field coordinator running the camp, and she walked me out in the woods with one of the refugees, Abu Khair, to show me the trap that he'd built to catch the boars. It wasn't what I pictured. And what is it, a dumpster?
米米·卡米里是负责管理这个营地的现场协调员，她带着其中一名难民阿布·海尔带我走进树林，给我看他为了捕捉野猪而搭建的陷阱。它和我想象的完全不一样。这是什么，一个垃圾桶吗？
Yes, it's a dumpster. And so he has put a piece of meat inside in order to attract the animals.
是的，是个垃圾桶。他放了一块肉在里面，用来吸引动物。
The dumpster's turned on its side, and the lid was propped open with a log so a boar could just walk right in.
垃圾桶侧着放，盖子用一根木头支开，这样野猪就可以直接走进去。
This open. That food to animals.
就这样打开。那是给动物的食物。
Abu Khair grabs the lid.
阿布·海尔抓住了盖子。
If animals catch food, this closes.
如果动物抓到食物，这个就会关上。
So basically the lid closes, and then the log comes down and holds it shut.
所以基本上盖子会关上，然后木头掉下来把它顶住。
And this thing.
还有这个东西。
[CLAPPING]
[鼓掌]
He claps his hands. I didn't say anything, but it did not seem at all clear that that lid was going to stay on with an angry, 200 pound pig inside. Before I got to Greece, I knew that there were lots of refugees there, fleeing violence from Syria, and Iraq, and Afghanistan, just like everybody had seen those photos last year of people landing in Greece by boat on their way to Germany and other European countries. Then this year, in March, one of the European nations said basically, "We're not taking you. You have to stay in Greece," to all these refugees.
他拍了拍手。我没说什么，但那盖子看起来一点也不稳，真要是有一头 200 磅愤怒的猪关在里面，它根本关不住。在去希腊之前，我就知道那里有很多难民，为了逃离叙利亚、伊拉克和阿富汗的暴力冲突。就像去年大家看到的那些照片，人们乘船抵达希腊，然后前往德国和其他欧洲国家。后来到了今年 3 月，其中一个欧洲国家基本上说：“我们不接收你们了。你们必须留在希腊。”所有的这些难民都被困住了。
Suddenly, the poorest country in Western Europe had to figure out how to house, and feed, and care for all these people, about 57,000 of them, stuck. And Greece was really not prepared. Its government was limping along after six years of austerity measures, which means, if you haven't been following this, there have been several waves of cutbacks in government services. A fourth of the country is out of work.
突然间，西欧最贫穷的国家必须想办法安置、喂养和照顾所有这些人，大约 57,000 人，他们都困在这里。希腊确实没有做好准备。在经历了六年的紧缩措施后，政府步履蹒跚。这意味着，如果你没关注过此事，政府服务已经经历了数轮削减。全国四分之一的人失业了。
The government quickly ad hocced its way into housing for tens of thousands of people. And as a result, you have this camp in the woods with wild boars. And 130 miles away on the coast, some Syrian refugees were living in an abandoned beach resort on the Ionian Sea.
政府迅速地临时凑出了可容纳数万人的住所。结果就是，你在森林里有了这样一个带野猪的营地。而在 130 英里外的海岸边，一些叙利亚难民住在了爱奥尼亚海边一个废弃的海滨度假胜地。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Kids play in the sand, and modestly dressed women in long sleeves, and long pants, and headscarves walk straight into the surf. Elsewhere around the country, if you want to come with me right now on a quick tour, around 1,300 Iraqis are housed in the grounds of a former psychiatric hospital near Mount Olympus. Down in Athens, 2,000 people are in two stadiums, baseball and field hockey, left over from the 2004 Olympic games.
孩子们在沙滩上玩耍，穿着保守、长袖长裤并戴着头巾的女性直接走进浪花里。在全国其他地方，如果你想现在跟我一起快速参观一下，大约 1300 名伊拉克人被安置在奥林匹斯山附近一所前精神病院的场地上。在雅典，2000 人住在两个体育场里，分别是 2004 年奥运会留下的棒球场和曲棍球场。
Somebody has spray painted a sign outside that says, in English, with arrows, "hockey, baseball, refugees." Next door to the stadiums, 1,000 people are living in an old international airport that closed back in 2001. There are departure boards, listing flights to Paris and Berlin with specific times and gates, from when it was still a functioning airport. Right nearby, the people sleeping in tents weren't going anywhere.
有人在外面喷漆写了一个标牌，用英语画了箭头，写着“曲棍球、棒球、难民”。在体育场隔壁，1000 人住在一个 2001 年关闭的旧国际机场里。那里还有离境显示屏，列出了飞往巴黎和柏林的航班，带有具体的时间和登机口，那是它还是一个运作中的机场时留下的。就在附近，睡在帐篷里的人哪儿也去不了。
Meanwhile, up north, near the Macedonian border, my colleague, This American Life producer Sean Cole, visited a highway rest stop that is pretty much exactly like any rest stop you would find on, like, the New Jersey turnpike or I-80 driving to Chicago. Inside, there's a convenience store with Pringles, and Oreos, and sodas. And then outside, where the gas pumps are, were pop tents with 2,000 people living in them, music playing.
与此同时，在北方靠近马其顿边境的地方，我的同事，本节目制作人肖恩·科尔参观了一个高速公路休息站。它几乎和你在新泽西收费公路或去往芝加哥的 80 号州际公路上能找到的任何休息站一模一样。里面有一家便利店，卖品客薯片、奥利奥和苏打水。而在外面，也就是加油泵所在的地方，搭着临时帐篷，住着 2000 人，播放着音乐。
People sat around the gas pumps, chatting and smoking right there, which probably not the best idea. An eight-year-old boy walked up to Sean and his interpreter Manaf with a request.
人们坐在加油泵周围，就在那里聊天抽烟，这可能不是什么好主意。一个八岁的男孩走到肖恩和他的口译员马纳夫面前提出了一个请求。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yes, I would like to take your passport.
是的，我想拿你的护照。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
To go to Germany.
去德国。
So you would pose as me?
所以你想冒充我？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I will get the same haircut.
我会理个同样的发型。
I think they would still be able to tell the difference.
我想他们还是能看出区别的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Would you make a passport for me, then?
那你给我画一本护照怎么样？
I could maybe draw one.
也许我可以画一本。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
What do you think about this place?
你觉得这个地方怎么样？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It's not beautiful.
它不美。
This gas station camp, by the way, was not an official refugee camp set up by the state. In fact, just a few days after Sean was there, the government relocated everybody to authorized camps. To give you a sense of just how seat-of-the-pants the Greek response to the refugee crisis has been, I talked to this guy who managed a camp of about 2,000 refugees when he was there. His name is Sakis Papithemilis. He's a civil servant. He chooses his words thoughtfully. And who, by the way, has his own salary cut in half over the last four years.
顺便说一下，这个加油站营地不是政府设立的官方难民营。事实上，肖恩去过那里几天后，政府就把所有人都转移到了授权营地。为了让你了解希腊对难民危机的反应有多么仓促，我采访了一个人，他在那里时负责管理一个约 2000 名难民的营地。他的名字叫萨基斯·帕皮塞米利斯。他是一名公务员。他措辞谨慎。顺便提一下，他的薪水在过去四年里被减半了。
NPR'S reporter in Greece, Joanna Kakissis, introduced me to him. She guided, actually, a lot of the reporting that we did around Greece. Sakis told Joanna and me that even trying to do something straightforward in the camp that he managed, like, for example, arrange for trash pickup, he would run into an incredibly basic problem.
美国国家公共电台驻希腊记者乔安娜·卡基西斯把我介绍给了他。事实上，她指导了我们在希腊进行的大部分报道。萨基斯告诉乔安娜和我，即使是在他管理的营地里尝试做一些简单的事情，比如安排垃圾收集，他也会遇到一个极其基本的问题。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
With the trash, for example, I couldn't organize the trash being picked up, because legally the camp didn't exist. The camp just wasn't there on paper.
以垃圾为例，我无法组织垃圾收集工作，因为在法律上，这个营地不存在。在文件上，这个营地根本就不存在。
Got that? The camps were created so quickly that nobody made them into any kind of legal entity. They weren't a business. They weren't a government agency. So they didn't have the power to actually sign any kind of contract with anyone to do anything.
听懂了吗？这些营地建立得太快，以至于没有人把它们变成任何形式的合法实体。它们不是企业。它们不是政府机构。所以它们没有权力与任何人签署任何合同来做任何事情。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
And everything had to be done with a handshake. OK, you want to help me? Come over here and help me.
一切都必须靠握手来完成。好吧，你想帮我吗？过来帮我。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
He's saying the municipalities helped a lot.
他说塞萨洛尼基市提供了很大帮助。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
He said that in the end, the city of Thessaloniki agreed to pick up his trash. And they paid for it too, just 'cause he needed the help. And then he had to work around this same exact frustrating problem to get anything done. To get food brought in, to install proper sewage, to install proper showers and toilets, just anything, he couldn't make a legal agreement. He had to go off the books.
他说最终塞萨洛尼基市同意帮他清理垃圾。他们也付了钱，只是因为他需要帮助。然后他必须绕过同样令人沮丧的问题才能完成任何事情。要运进食物，安装排污设施，安装淋浴间和厕所，任何事情，他都无法签署法律协议。他必须在账外运作。
Four of us from our staff traveled to Greece. We were joined by Joanna, who's been reporting on this and breaking stories on the refugee crisis for two years now. We were interested in how the Greek government was dealing with the refugees, but honestly, we also wanted to know what it was like for all these people who, you know, they thought they were heading somewhere else in Europe, and now they were stuck in these camps, in this weird kind of limbo, where they're just waiting for some country to let them in, and they can restart their lives. It's just a strange place to find yourself.
我们四名工作人员前往了希腊。乔安娜加入了我们，她已经在报道这件事并报道难民危机两年的时间了。我们对希腊政府如何处理难民问题很感兴趣，但老实说，我们也想知道对于这些人来说情况如何，你知道，他们以为自己正前往欧洲的其他地方，现在却被困在这些营地里，处于一种奇怪的困境中，他们在等待某个国家让他们进去，这样他们就可以重新开始生活。发现自己身处这种地方真是很奇怪。
Outside the old international airport, by a hot dog stand just across the highway from the beach, which is there also, Marzia and her husband Jamal and their three kids are living in a little tent. It's really hot, and every day, a fancy green convertible Saab parks outside their tent. And every day, Marzia goes and sits in the shade of that car to cool herself off.
在旧国际机场外，公路对面靠近海滩的一个热狗摊旁边——海滩也在那里，马尔齐亚和她的丈夫贾马尔以及他们的三个孩子住在一个小帐篷里。天气非常热，每天都有一辆时髦的绿色萨博敞篷车停在他们的帐篷外。每天，马尔齐亚都会坐在那辆车的阴凉处让自己凉快下来。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
She's saying, sometimes its get so crazy. I'm tired of the sun, of this place, everything. And she says the hotter it gets, the more she loses it. Which means--
她说，有时候这太疯狂了。我厌倦了阳光，厌倦了这个地方，厌倦了一切。她说天气越热，她就越崩溃。这意味着——
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Pretty much every day she loses it. She and her husband Jamal talk to another This American Life producer, Miki Meek. They're ethnic Hazaras, who are discriminated against in Afghanistan, where they're from, and also targeted by the Taliban. So they moved to Iran for a while, where they have no rights at all. Couldn't even put their kids in school. And then they ended up here five months ago, where Jamal is getting used to his wife basically freaking out every single day, and telling him they need to give up and go back.
基本上每天她都会崩溃。她和她的丈夫贾马尔与本节目的另一位制作人米基·米克进行了交谈。他们是哈扎拉族人，在他们的家乡阿富汗受到歧视，也是塔利班的目标。所以他们在伊朗住了一段时间，在那里他们没有任何权利。甚至不能让孩子上学。然后五个月前他们到了这里，贾马尔已经习惯了他的妻子基本上每天都在崩溃，告诉他他们需要放弃并回去。
Today, my wife was just crying that I had it. You gotta make a decision-- either we go back, or we move forward. And I explained to her, look, my dear. We can't go back, because there's nothing to go back to. And moving forward is no longer in my hands. The border is closed. So then I said, darling, let's go to the beach. And perhaps that will help you, like, just calm down for a moment. And it did.
今天，我的妻子只是在哭，我受够了。你必须做一个决定——我们要么回去，要么向前走。我向她解释，看，亲爱的。我们不能回去，因为那里什么都没有了。而向前走已经不在我的掌控之中了。边境关闭了。所以我说，亲爱的，我们去海滩吧。也许那会帮你，比如，冷静片刻。而且确实管用。
Are you worried about move might stop working eventually? Let's go to the beach?"
你担心“尝试可能最终会失效。我们去海滩吧”吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Yeah, I'm thinking about it. You know, this is another worry for me. So if this doesn't work, I'll find another way to please her and make her happy.
是的，我在考虑这件事。你知道，这是我的另一个担忧。所以如果这个行不通，我会想办法哄她开心，让她幸福。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have stories of people on the run who get stuck in this place they do not want to be, what that's like. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，我们讲述了在逃亡途中却被困在不想去的地方的人们的故事，了解那是怎样的感觉。请继续收听。
Act 1, Field of Interrupted Dreams. So one good place to see how the Greeks' ad hoc response is working is at the baseball stadium in Athens. About a fourth of the refugees in Greece are from Afghanistan, and about 1,000 of them were brought into this abandoned stadium that was left over from the Olympics. The infield was all dirt. One of our producers, Miki, went there.
第一幕，中断的梦想领域。所以，看看希腊临时反应如何运作的一个好地方是雅典的棒球场。希腊大约四分之一的难民来自阿富汗，大约 1000 人被带到了这个奥林匹克运动会留下的废弃体育场。内场全是泥土。我们的制作人米基去了那里。
Here's how you turn a baseball stadium into a refugee camp. Out in the door of the infield and the outfield you set up 150 white tents. They're standard issue from the UN. At the concession stand, give out rations. Right behind home plate, there's a press box. Make that the office. For bathrooms, use the locker rooms behind the dugouts. There's one for men and one for women. The women's is way cleaner.
这就是你如何把棒球场变成难民营的方法。在内场和外场的门外搭起 150 个白色帐篷。它们是联合国的标准配给。在小卖部，分发口粮。本垒后面是媒体中心。把它变成办公室。对于洗手间，使用更衣室后的更衣室。男士一个，女士一个。女士的要干净得多。
We're walking to the women's area.
我们正在走向女性区域。
The women are very organized. They have a list. They clean the bathrooms twice a day.
女性非常有组织。她们有一份名单。她们每天清洁洗手间两次。
The women?
女性？
Men are not better organized. We have to drag them to clean their bathroom.
男性没有更好的组织。我们必须把他们拖去打扫他们的洗手间。
One of the camps managers, Anna Agriteli, is giving me a tour. She has big brown hair pulled into a ponytail. She's Greek. So we're just walking into the locker room. And the floors are a little flooded, so we're just walking through a pool water. All the lockers and benches have been ripped out. And over in the showers, women are squatting with buckets full of water and clothing.
营地经理之一安娜·阿格里特利正在带我参观。她有一头深棕色的大头发扎成马尾辫。她是希腊人。所以我们正走进更衣室。地板有点淹水，所以我们正穿过一池水。所有的储物柜和长椅都被拆除了。在淋浴区，女性正蹲在装满水和衣服的桶旁。
11 showers.
11 个淋浴间。
Now they're washing their clothes.
现在她们在洗衣服。
Laundry, they're doing laundry now. So does this just get flooded just from the people doing their laundry?
洗衣，她们现在在洗衣服。所以这里是因为人们洗衣服而淹水的吗？
Their laundry, yes.
她们的洗衣，是的。
OK. I counted 12 toilets. Only six were working. This was for 300 women and about 200 girls. Did you ever go to a baseball game during the Olympics?
好的。我数了 12 个厕所。只有 6 个在工作。这是给 300 名女性和大约 200 名女孩使用的。你参加过奥运会期间的棒球比赛吗？
No. We are not big fans of baseball in Greece. We don't even know baseball.
没有。我们在希腊不是棒球的大粉丝。我们甚至不懂棒球。
Most of the refugees stay out of their tents during the day, because they're too hot. They're totally exposed on the field, no shade. Temperatures right now reach into the 90s. So lots of people hang out in the upper levels of the stadium seats, because they're partially covered by an overhanging roof. They also crowd around any electrical outlet they can find to charge phones or plug in electric tea pots. The Olympics were held here. I keep thinking that.
大多数难民白天会待在帐篷外，因为里面太热了。他们在场地上完全暴露，没有阴凉。现在的气温达到 90 多华氏度。所以很多人待在体育场座位的上层，因为它们部分被悬垂的屋顶遮盖。他们也挤在任何能找到的电源插座旁给手机充电或插上电动茶壶。奥运会曾在这里举行。我一直在想这件事。
Anna is in charge of everything in the stadium, everything-- a woman who didn't get shampoo when they handed it out, the broken toilets. The day I was there, they didn't have enough drinking water and baby formula to get through the coming week. She takes me over to homebase, where they built a prototype cover for the tents, these giant pieces of green sheer fabric stretched over a tent to try and cool it down in the sun.
安娜负责体育场里的一切，一切——一个没领到洗发水的女性，坏掉的厕所。我在那天，他们没有足够的饮用水和婴儿配方奶粉来支撑接下来的一周。她带我到本垒板，他们在那里搭建了一个帐篷的原型盖，这些巨大的绿色薄织物块覆盖在帐篷上，试图在阳光下让它凉快下来。
This is sample. See if it works. But we don't like it, and we're going to change it.
这是一个样品。看看它是否有效。但我们不喜欢它，我们要换掉它。
So is it not working well? Or what would you guys want?
所以它效果不好？或者你们想要什么？
No, it's very, very bad. And if you put 150 of those, then I'm not going to see the people.
不，它非常非常糟糕。如果你放 150 个那种东西，那我就看不到人们了。
She needs to see the people, in case there's a fire or some other disturbance. It's happened. This is Anna's third month on the job. Before this, she worked as a production assistant at a theater company.
她需要看到人们，以防发生火灾或其他骚乱。这已经发生过了。这是安娜工作的第三个月。在此之前，她在一家剧院公司担任制作助理。
Is there anything that you learned in that job that's useful in this job?
你在那份工作中是否有学到对这份工作有用的东西？
No. But maybe the production, the crazy hours that you work in the production, that's the same, and that you have to devise a solution for every crazy thing.
没有。但也许是制作，你在制作中工作的疯狂小时数，是一样的，而且你必须为每件疯狂的事情制定一个解决方案。
Situations that come up, you have to, like, work on the fly. Anna, old are you?
出现的状况，你必须，比如，临时处理。安娜，你多大？
30.
30岁。
She's actually older than a lot of her coworkers. It's mostly women working at the camp. Anna's boss is 25. 25 years old and overseeing the biggest camp in Athens, working out of a concession stand that probably sold hot dogs.
她其实比很多同事都大。营地里主要是女性在工作。安娜的老板是 25 岁。25 岁，负责监管雅典最大的营地，在可能曾经卖热狗的小卖部里办公。
So why is it that it's mostly very young women that are working in here and managing this camp?
那么为什么在这里工作和管理这个营地的大多是年轻女性？
Because this job is very hard, and only women can do it.
因为这份工作非常艰难，只有女性才能做。
Is that your official or unofficial answer?
这是你的正式还是非正式回答？
No, no. It's the unofficial answer. You need to have a lot of power, a lot of hours.
不，不。这是非正式回答。你需要有很大的力量，很多的时间。
You have to be tireless.
你必须是不知疲倦的。
Yes.
是的。
At several of these camps we went to around Greece, the young women running them began as volunteers when the crisis started. Then they took charge. They worked long hours. They don't really take days off. And they set a tone at the camps. The government doesn't want the camps to feel like prisons. People can come and go. And having these young women in charge helps with that. They don't act like guards or bosses. They're just bad asses and sweethearts. Anna and the other woman who runs this stadium are constantly making these little jokes and laughing with everyone. Every few steps on our tour, Anna got stopped.
在我们去过的希腊几个营地中，管理它们的年轻女性都是在危机开始时以志愿者身份加入的。然后她们承担了重任。她们工作时间很长。她们其实没怎么休假。她们为营地奠定了基调。政府不想让营地感觉像监狱。人们可以来去自如。让这些年轻女性负责有助于这一点。她们表现得不像看守或老板。她们只是狠角色和甜心。安娜和运营这个体育场的另一位女性一直在和每个人开玩笑和欢笑。在我们的参观途中，安娜每走几步就会被拦住。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Do you get hugs a lot?
你经常得到拥抱吗？
Yes.
是的。
How many times a day or do you think you get hugged?
你觉得你一天被拥抱多少次？
Too many, too many, too many.
太多，太多，太多。
Well, I guess there's worse things people can do than hug you, right?
嗯，我想人们能对你做的事情里还有比拥抱更糟糕的，对吧？
Yes, yes. They could throw rocks at me. No, they're all very polite. And men, they're very polite and very protective.
是的，是的。他们可能会朝我扔石头。不，他们都非常有礼貌。男人们，他们非常有礼貌而且非常保护人。
Like, when she walks to the bus stop on the highway late at night, five or six men always walk out with her to make sure she's safe. They won't leave until they see her board the bus.
比如，当她深夜走到高速公路的公交车站时，总有五六个男人陪着她一起走，以确保她安全。直到看到她上了公交车，他们才离开。
OK, you wait here outside.
好的，你在这外面等。
In the span of 15 minutes, I watched Anna comfort a woman who came to her to say that she was feeling suicidal. Her husband was ignoring her. Anna then went to find help for a guy who kept fainting.
在 15 分钟内，我看着安娜安慰了一位来告诉她自己有自杀念头的女性。她的丈夫无视她。安娜随后去帮一个一直在晕倒的家伙寻找医疗帮助。
My friend, wait here. Don't go without seeing the doctor. Come after to the office. Tell me what happened.
我的朋友，在这等。没有看医生不要走。之后到办公室来。告诉我发生了什么。
Moments later, a boy ran up to her to say that he was hungry, that he didn't get lunch.
片刻之后，一个男孩跑向她说他饿了，没吃午餐。
No, no. You got food.
不，不。你拿到食物了。
No, I didn't, madame, no!
没有，我没有，夫人，没有！
But I saw you. But I saw you.
但我看见你了。但我看见你了。
She'd seen him grab food from the kitchen earlier in the day, she told me. Because she can't speak Dari, Anna mostly communicates through a combination of broken English, hand gestures, and [MEOWING] animal noises. That's Anna making cat sounds.
她告诉我，她早些时候看到他从厨房拿了食物。因为她不会说达里语，安娜主要通过蹩脚的英语、手势和[猫叫声]动物叫声进行交流。那是安娜发出的猫叫声。
[OINKING]
[猪叫声]
That's the pig, her favorite. I watched Anna oink her way down crowded hallways, oinking as she hands out juice boxes to kids.
那是猪，她最喜欢的。我看着安娜在拥挤的走廊里一边猪叫一边走，当她给孩子们分发果汁盒时也发出猪叫声。
Here, my friend!
给，我的朋友！
Oinking the middle of conversations with adults.
在与成年人的谈话中也发出猪叫声。
You always make this little pig sound.
你总是发出这种小猪的声音。
I don't know why I do it. It's like a tick.
我不知道为什么这么做。这就像一种抽搐。
She says it's like a tick. Given Anna's personality, the hardest part of her job might be obvious. It's saying "no."
她说这就像一种抽搐。鉴于安娜的个性，她工作中可能最困难的部分显而易见。那就是说“不”。
Like every two, three days, I'll have a breakdown because the nos that I say, they are a lot.
就像每两三天，我就会崩溃一次，因为我说的不字，真的很多。
You say a lot of nos.
你说了很多不。
Yes, when I say to somebody "no," I feel very bad. Because in my personal life, I never used to say no.
是的，当我对某人说不的时候，我感觉很糟糕。因为在我的个人生活中，我从不习惯说不。
You did? I'm not so good at saying no either.
你做到了？我也不太擅长说不。
Yes.
是的。
It's hard.
这很难。
Come and work here. You'll get used to it in a month.
来这工作吧。一个月你就习惯了。
What are people always asking you for?
人们总是找你要什么？
Shoes.
鞋子。
Is it shoes?
是鞋子吗？
Yes, shoes are the most asked for thing here. "I want shoes now."
是的，鞋子是这里需求量最大的东西。“我现在想要鞋子。”
And what do you say?
那你怎么说？
"You have to wait."
“你得等。”
She says they've already given out sneakers twice in the past three months to everyone. But every day, she says, she gets this request over and over, mostly from young men. As if on cue, two guys, most likely in their 20s, show up.
她说在过去三个月里，他们已经给每个人发过两次运动鞋了。但她说每天她都会一次又一次地收到这个要求，大多来自年轻男性。仿佛配合cue点一样，两个大概 20 多岁的家伙出现了。
Eh? Shoes?
呃？鞋子？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Anna tells them no. And I guess she's had so much practice with this one, as you heard, she doesn't even hesitate. Anna moves on, but it's a puzzle to her. Why the constant need for more shoes?
安娜告诉他们不行。我想她在这件事上已经练习过很多次了，正如你听到的，她甚至没有犹豫。安娜继续往前走，但这对她来说是个谜。为什么总是需要更多的鞋子？
Later, I'm wandering around the tents in the ball field with my interpreter, and we're talking to a guy who lives near third base. And we accidentally discover the answer. His name's Habib. He's 45. He's Afghan, like most everyone in the stadium. He tells me back home in Kabul, he was a shoemaker. So I have to ask.
后来，我和我的口译员在球场的帐篷间徘徊，我们正和一个住在三垒附近的人交谈，我们偶然发现了答案。他叫哈比卜。他 45 岁。他是阿富汗人，就像体育场里的绝大多数人一样。他告诉我，在喀布尔老家，他是一名鞋匠。所以我必须问。
So I was talking to the camp manager, and she said the number one thing people ask for here is shoes. Why?
我刚才和营地经理谈过，她说人们在这里要求的头号东西是鞋子。为什么？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
I can tell you the reason why-- Afghans.
我可以告诉你原因——阿富汗人。
There are two reasons, actually. One is, they don't wear shoes in their tents, and sneakers are a pain to take on and off if you have to fuss with the laces. So they smash in the backs of the shoes and wear them like slippers. The second reason is, and here Habib started making a kicking motion with his feet.
其实有两个原因。一是他们不在帐篷里穿鞋，而且如果你得系鞋带，运动鞋穿脱很麻烦。所以他们把鞋后跟踩扁，像拖鞋一样穿。第二个原因是，这时哈比卜开始用脚做出踢球的动作。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
The reason is because Afghans love to play soccer.
原因是阿富汗人喜欢踢足球。
The younger guys destroyed their shoes so fast because they are always playing soccer at a field nearby. That's it. Not much of a mystery after all. Habib says there's not much for people to do at the camp, and soccer helps them break up the boredom.
年轻人因为总是在附近的球场踢足球，所以把鞋子损坏得很快。就是这样。毕竟没什么神秘的。哈比卜说营地里没什么事可做，足球帮助他们打发无聊。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
So it's like this-- you wake up in the morning. We look at each other. There's nothing. Then we go and have breakfast. Then we come back and sit and look at each other. There's nothing else. We used to have some playing cards, and then somebody stole it. So we try to listen to music on the cell phones. And then we look at each other again. And then it's afternoon. Then we go and have some lunch. And then we come back and sit here and then look at each other again.
情况是这样的——你早上醒来。我们看着彼此。什么都没有。然后我们去吃早餐。然后我们回来坐着，看着彼此。没别的了。我们过去有一些扑克牌，然后有人偷了。所以我们试着在手机上听音乐。然后我们又看着彼此。然后就是下午了。然后我们去吃点午餐。然后我们回来坐在这里，然后又看着彼此。
And then we just fall asleep. We take a long nap until 6:00 PM. And then at 6:00 PM, we go and play some soccer. And then we come back here, have dinner. And then we look at each other again, and then we fall asleep.
然后我们就睡着了。我们一直睡到下午 6 点。然后下午 6 点，我们去踢会儿足球。然后我们回到这里，吃晚餐。然后我们又看着彼此，然后我们就睡着了。
So you're pretty sick of looking at each other now.
所以你现在对看着彼此感到很厌烦了。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
You know, the thing is, you have to understand. Today, you guys came here, and we talked. And I don't even-- the time, how it passed. But on normal days, regular days, one hour to us passes like one whole year of boredom.
你知道，重点是，你得明白。今天你们来了，我们谈了谈。我甚至——时间，是怎么过的。但在平时的日子里，正常的日子，对我们来说一小时就像一整年的无聊。
There's a pretty nice public beach that's only a 15 minute walk from the stadium. Habib says he takes his kids there a few times a week, but never on weekends.
从体育场步行 15 分钟有一个相当不错的公共海滩。哈比卜说他每周带孩子们去那里几次，但从不在周末去。
Not on Saturdays and Sundays, because it's the Greeks' holidays, and we want them to enjoy the beach themselves.
不在周六和周日，因为那是希腊人的假期，我们想让他们自己享受海滩。
He wanted them to have the beach to themselves? Really? I asked him if that was it, or was it that he just felt uncomfortable among the Greeks.
他想让他们独自拥有海滩？真的吗？我问他是否就是这样，还是他只是觉得在希腊人中间感到不自在。
Is there any part that you wouldn't go to the beach because maybe you would feel like you may not be wanted there?
有没有哪部分你不会去海滩，因为也许你会觉得自己在那里可能不受欢迎？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
They're very nice people. I don't feel uncomfortable. But when it comes to the beach situation, it's like, OK, we heard that the Greeks had complained that there are a lot of Afghans coming to the beach, and it was getting too crowded for them.
他们是非常好的人。我没有感到不自在。但说到海滩的情况，就好像，好吧，我们听说希腊人抱怨有太多的阿富汗人去海滩，对他们来说太拥挤了。
So we came here. We talked with each other and we decided we don't want the Greeks to have a bad memory of us. So we decided on Saturdays and Sundays, we want them to go and enjoy themselves. And we don't want them to feel like we're there to take their space.
所以我们来了这里。我们互相谈过，我们决定不希望希腊人对我们有不好的记忆。所以我们决定在周六和周日，我们要让他们去享受美好时光。我们不希望他们觉得我们是在抢占他们的空间。
About 3,000 people live in this complex, which includes this stadium, a field hockey stadium next door, and an old airport out front. And everyone I talked to knew this rule-- let the Greeks have the beach on the weekend.
大约 3000 人住在这个综合体里，包括这个体育场、隔壁的曲棍球场和一个外面的旧机场。我交谈过的每个人都知道这条规则——周末让希腊人拥有海滩。
Most of the Afghans have very little sense of what's going on outside the camp. There's no Wi-Fi here. They're barely getting news from outside. And I didn't meet anyone who spoke Greek. They're living in a bubble, a baseball field shaped bubble. So rumors go crazy. Most of them have to do with when, and how, or if they will get out of Greece.
大多数阿富汗人对营地外发生的事情知之甚少。这里没有 Wi-Fi。他们几乎得不到外面的新闻。而且我没遇到一个会说希腊语的人。他们生活在一个泡泡里，一个棒球场形状的泡泡。所以流言蜚语非常疯狂。大多数与他们何时、如何，或者是否会离开希腊有关。
Here's a few of them-- Angela Merkel, the German chancellor is personally coming to the stadium to rescue them. John Kerry is bringing a plane. The Canadians are sending a ship. And the most common-- Macedonia is going to reopen its borders again to Afghans.
这是其中一些流言——德国总理安格拉·默克尔正亲自来到体育场来营救他们。约翰·克里正在派飞机。加拿大人正派船。而最常见的一个——马其顿将再次向阿富汗人重新开放边境。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
Literally, like, we would hear the border has reopened. We're throwing a party, started dancing, clapping, cheering, hugging each other, congratulating each other. And then some people have literally left overnight to go to the border. And then in the morning we hear it was just a rumor.
真的，就像，我们会听说边境已经重新开放了。我们举行派对，开始跳舞、鼓掌、欢呼、拥抱彼此，互相祝贺。然后在早上我们听说那只是个谣言。
When was the last time that there was a party because people believed the border was opening?
上一次因为人们相信边境开放而举行派对是什么时候？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
The biggest one was about a month ago, but also about two weeks ago.
最大的一次是在一个月前，但两周前也有过。
How long does it take for a rumor to spread through a camp, this camp?
流言在一个营地里散布需要多长时间，这个营地？
You have to understand, people, they have nothing to do except going around talking to each other, so it spreads within minutes. And believing in it, thinking that it might be right, actually makes you happy for a couple of days.
你得明白，人们，他们没事可做，只能到处走动跟彼此交谈，所以几分钟内就会传开。而相信它，认为它可能是对的，实际上会让你开心几天。
In this stadium full of Afghans, one big piece of misinformation is about Syrians and how they're treated in Greece. In February, when the border closed to Afghans, Syrians were still being allowed through. Habib and his family watched Syrians cross over. Violent fights broke out that day between the two groups, and have continued ever since. It's one of the reasons why the Greek government segregates most of its camps by nationality. So there are no Syrians in this stadium, which Habib explains this way.
在这个满是阿富汗人的体育场里，有一个关于叙利亚人以及他们如何在希腊受到对待的大错觉。二月，当边境对阿富汗人关闭时，叙利亚人仍然被允许通过。那天这两个群体之间爆发了激烈的战斗，并且从那以后一直持续。这就是希腊政府按国籍隔离大多数营地的原因之一。所以这个体育场里没有叙利亚人，哈比卜是这样解释的。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
Look, Syrians are getting to stay in very nice hotels. Everybody cares about them, and they are issued visas right here, and then they get to fly out of Greece. So if the border's closed, it doesn't matter to them.
你看，叙利亚人能住进非常好的酒店。每个人都关心他们，他们就在这里被发放签证，然后他们可以飞出希腊。所以如果边境关闭，对他们来说没关系。
Are there Syrians in this camp?
这个营地里有叙利亚人吗？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
They're not in this camp, and I don't think they're in any other camps. They're living in hotels.
他们不在这家营地，我想他们不在任何其他营地。他们住在酒店里。
Last Friday, I was in a camp, and that camp was all Syrian, who are also stuck here. And I was wondering if you knew that these camps full of Syrians exist here in Greece.
上周五，我在一个营地，那个营地全是叙利亚人，他们也困在这里。我一直在想你是否知道在希腊这里存在这些满是叙利亚人的营地。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
I've heard that there are Syrians here, but I haven't seen them here.
我听说这里有叙利亚人，但我没在这里见过他们。
Do the majority of people here believe that Syrians are getting flown out on airplanes?
这里的大多数人相信叙利亚人正在被飞机接走吗？
Everybody believes here, because it's not a rumor, actually. They do fly Syrians out of here. You have to understand the difference between them and us, the Syrians and Afghans, is that for them they have help.
每个人在这里都相信，因为它实际上不是谣言。他们确实用飞机把叙利亚人接出这里。你得理解他们和我们之间的区别，叙利亚人和阿富汗人，对于他们来说他们有帮助。
Habib isn't exactly right about everything, but he's correct that there's a pecking order among the refugees, and Syrians are at the very top. They get top priority on their asylum and relocation applications for the EU. And then underneath the Syrians is pretty much everyone else-- Iraqis, Pakistanis, Iranians, and Afghans.
哈比卜并不完全正确，但他正确的是，难民之间存在等级制度，而叙利亚人处于最顶端。他们在欧盟的庇护和重新安置申请中享有最高优先权。在叙利亚人之下的是几乎所有人——伊拉克人、巴基斯坦人、伊朗人和阿富汗人。
Miki Meek. Act 2, the parents, trapped. So what's it like being a parent in this situation? Kids are everywhere in the camps. They're a third of the refugees. You see them running around, improvising stuff to play with. You'll be standing there, and a four-year-old will march by, purposefully dragging a blanket on a string. And you'll think, OK.
米基·米克。第二幕，父母，困境。那么作为父母在这种情况下是什么感觉？营地里到处都是孩子。他们占了难民的三分之一。你看到他们跑来跑去，即兴利用东西玩耍。你会站在那里，一个四岁的孩子会走过，有目的地拖着一根绳子系着的毯子。你会想，好吧。
The woman in charge of the Ritsona camp, the camp with the wild pigs, told me that it's the little kids who are doing better than anybody at the camps. And on the surface, watching them run around, they do seem good, like these five and seven-year-old sisters.
负责里特索纳营地——那个有野猪的营地——的那位女性告诉我，在营地里，小孩子比任何人表现得都好。从表面上看，看着他们跑来跑去，他们确实看起来不错，就像这两个五岁和七岁的姐妹。
Doing what I can tell you from experience any little kids do around a microphone anywhere in the world.
做着我凭经验可以告诉你世界任何地方的小孩子对着麦克风会做的事情。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
One girl goofs on the mic saying, "bye, uncle" over and over. And her sister calls her crazy.
一个女孩对着麦克风胡闹，不停地喊“再见，叔叔”。她的姐姐叫她疯子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So they seem fine, right? But scratch the surface a little, and it's a different story. That five-year-old? Her mom tells me she's still so traumatized by the Syrian War and what she's been through that when her mom wants to go to the bathroom, the little girl insists on coming in with her. She's always by her side. Lots of kids are still recovering.
所以他们看起来很好，对吧？但稍微深究一下，就是另一回事了。那个五岁的女孩？她妈妈告诉我她仍然因为叙利亚战争和她经历的一切而受到如此大的创伤，以至于当她妈妈想去洗手间时，那个小女孩坚持要跟进去。她总是待在妈妈身边。许多孩子仍在恢复中。
A guy named Youness Aselom told me about his five-year-old. Youness was a second year law student back in Syria, but in the camp he's famous for being the guy that when a snake gets into your tent, Youness can catch it. If it's poisonous, he'll kill it. He's getting maybe one a day.
一个叫尤尼斯·阿塞洛姆的人告诉了我他五岁孩子的事。尤尼斯在叙利亚时是法律系二年级的学生，但在营地里他很有名，因为当有蛇钻进你的帐篷时，尤尼斯能抓住它。如果是毒蛇，他会杀死它。他大概一天能抓一条。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I'll get, like, a stick, like a long stick. And I'll just start to play with the snake. And I can show you a photo, but once I can get a stick right on top of the snake's head, I'll press down on it, so the snake's head is against the ground. And I'll just grab its head from behind. See, like in this picture right here?
我会拿，比如一根棍子，一根长棍子。我就开始跟那条蛇玩。我能给你看张照片，但只要我能把棍子正好压在蛇头上，我就会按下去，这样蛇头就被压在地上了。我就从后面抓住它的头。看，就像这张照片里这样？
Anyway, his daughters. Being in the camp, of course, is way better than living with constant bombs and shooting back in Syria. A number of parents tell me that the kids are sleeping better, getting back to their old selves. They get to come and go as they please, which is too dangerous back home, to play with other kids.
无论如何，他的女儿们。待在营地里，当然比待在叙利亚不断有炸弹和枪击的地方好得多。许多家长告诉我，孩子们睡得更好，正恢复到他们原来的样子。他们可以随心所欲地来去，这在老家太危险了，可以和其他孩子一起玩。
But Youness says his daughters are not OK at all, and not happy.
但尤尼斯说他的女儿们一点都不好，也不开心。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I have a daughter who has psychological problems. A rocket fell on our house, and my mom and my other daughter were killed.
我有一个女儿有心理问题。一枚火箭落在我们的房子上，我和我妈还有另一个女儿都被杀了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The house was destroyed. His five-year-old, the one in the camp, was three at the time. And since then?
房子被毁了。他的五岁女儿，现在在营地里的那个，当时三岁。从那以后？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And she became afraid of the sounds of airplanes. And now they have us in an air base. And now when a military jet passes over us, you know what? She starts to cry.
她开始害怕飞机的声音。而现在他们把我们安置在一个空军基地。现在当一架军用喷气式飞机经过我们上空时，你知道吗？她开始哭。
Has she made friends?
她交到朋友了吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
No, she doesn't. She doesn't have any friends. I mean, she never leaves the tent.
没有，她没有。她没有任何朋友。我是说，她从不出帐篷。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And then this is a picture of my daughter, the one that died.
这是我女儿的照片，死掉的那个。
The photo is shocking-- a cute three-year-old girl lying in rubble, dust on her face and clothes. It's hard to know what to say.
照片令人震惊——一个可爱的三岁女孩躺在瓦砾中，脸上和衣服上都是灰尘。真不知道该说什么。
So they're actually-- they're twins. The five-year-old, so this is her twin that died. She was three years old when she died.
所以她们实际上——她们是双胞胎。五岁的那个，所以这是死去的双胞胎。她死的时候三岁。
Did she see this?
她看到了这个吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yeah, she was with them when it happened. And this is our home.
是的，发生的时候她和她们在一起。这是我们的家。
I know this isn't the point of his story at all, but this happened a bunch of times in the camps. Somebody would describe the most awful thing that could ever happen, and then they would pull out their cell phones. Like, oh here's a picture. Here's the bombed out apartment that used to be our house. Here is an overloaded raft crossing from Turkey into Greece. That's my kids in the orange life jackets.
我知道这根本不是他故事的重点，但这在营地里发生了好几次。有人会描述可能发生的最糟糕的事情，然后他们会拿出手机。就像，哦这是照片。这是曾经是我们家的被炸毁的公寓。这是载满人的木筏从土耳其穿过进入希腊。那是穿着橙色救生衣的孩子们。
I suppose if you visit war zones all the time, this is nothing new. And of course people use cell phones for this, to record the near annihilation of their families. I would do it too. But it was always jolting.
我想如果你经常访问战区，这没什么新鲜的。当然人们会用手机记录这些，记录他们家庭的几乎毁灭。我也会这么做。但这总是令人震惊。
The interview that I did that gave me the best picture of what it's like to be a parent in the camps and the particular ways that it affected different members of a family to be here was an interview with a woman named Aziza Bashar. She's well dressed, even here, with a stylish hijab, a red and navy plaid button down jacket, and a steamlined navy skirt. It's like, what little she can control, she does.
我做的那个采访，让我对营地里的父母生活以及这种经历对家庭不同成员的具体影响有了最好的了解，那是一个名叫阿齐扎·巴沙尔的女性的采访。她衣着得体，即使在这里，也戴着时尚的头巾，穿着红蓝格子纽扣夹克，和一条流线型的深蓝色裙子。就像，她能控制的一点点事情，她就去做了。
Her husband's also in the camp, though he waved me off when I tried to talk to him. She's the one who makes the decisions for the family, who marched them out of a war zone, walking and actually sometimes running she said, to a town up north where things were safer. And when things there became untenable, she moved them again to Kurdistan where they lived for a while.
她丈夫也在营地里，虽然我试图和他交谈时，他挥手拒绝了我。她是家庭里做决定的人，是她带领他们走出战区，走路，有时甚至跑，她说，到一个北方更安全的小镇。当那里的情况变得无法维持时，她又搬到了库尔德斯坦，在那里住了一段时间。
And finally they just decided to escape to Europe. They arrived in Greece by boat, thinking they were just passing through just here for a few days. The child she worries about most of her kids is Mohammad, Hammed, they call him. He's nearly eight. When the war began, they were near Aleppo. Hammed was the child who reacted the worst to the bombing, and the snipers, and the shelling, which were constant for days sometimes.
最终他们决定逃往欧洲。他们乘船抵达希腊，以为他们只是路过，只在这里待几天。她最担心的孩子是穆罕默德，他们叫他哈米德。他快八岁了。当战争开始时，他们在阿勒颇附近。哈米德是对轰炸、狙击手和炮击反应最强烈的孩子，这些有时会持续几天。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
But the longest we were under siege for was eight days.
我们被围困最长的时间是八天。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Meaning that the fighting was going on day and night, nonstop.
意味着战斗没日没夜地进行，不停歇。
Hammed was four. He was potty trained, but he started wetting the bed. And he hasn't stopped wetting the bed years later now. His siblings all play together, but he's always off on the side. He doesn't interact.
哈米德四岁。他受过如厕训练，但开始尿床。几年后的现在他还没停止尿床。他的兄弟姐妹都在一起玩，但他总是待在一边。他不互动。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
When I took him to the doctor in Kurdistan, he told me he has developmental issues. They said your son is seven, but mentally he's four. He's stalled mentally. If you teach him anything, he doesn't remember it. If you ask him anything, he takes a long time to respond.
当我在库尔德斯坦带他去看医生时，他告诉我他有发育问题。他们说你的儿子七岁，但心理年龄是四岁。他心理停滞了。如果你教他任何东西，他都记不住。如果你问他任何问题，他需要很长时间才能回应。
She says before the war, he was developing normally. And in fact, getting stuck developmentally like this is one way that some children respond to trauma. What's your name?
她说战争前，他发育正常。事实上，像这样在发育上受阻是孩子们应对创伤的一种方式。你叫什么名字？
Hammed.
哈米德。
Hammed? What do you think of life here at the camp?
哈米德？你觉得在营地的生活怎么样？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
That's his mom prodding him.
那是他妈妈在催促他。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Like the other kids I met who were doing the worst, Hammed's big problem is fear. At first when they got to the camp, it was the snakes and the wild animals that he feared the most. But the family worked really hard on that, and now he's OK with the snakes. Next, it was the airplanes. And that became a family project. And now he's not so scared of the planes. Though the one thing they haven't been able to fix is his dreams. He dreams of bombings and shellings.
像我见过的其他表现最差的孩子一样，哈米德最大的问题是恐惧。刚到营地时，他最害怕的是蛇和野生动物。但家庭在这方面非常努力，现在他不再怕蛇了。接下来，是飞机。这成为了一个家庭项目。现在他不再那么怕飞机了。尽管有一件事他们还没能解决，那就是他的梦。他梦见轰炸和炮击。
So how in the world did you get this fearful child onto a little raft from Turkey to Greece?
那么你是怎么把这个恐惧的孩子带上从土耳其到希腊的木筏的呢？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He saw on TV before we left Kurdistan. He used to see the ocean in cartoons and say, "Mom, the water has sharks in it." And before we left, he saw in his dreams that a shark came up, the same as the cartoons, and he said, "It's gonna eat me. It's gonna eat me, and I'm gonna die."
他在我们离开库尔德斯坦之前在电视上看到了。他过去常在动画片里看到海洋，说，“妈妈，水里有鲨鱼。”在我们离开之前，他在梦里看到一条鲨鱼游过来，和动画片里一样，他说，“它要吃掉我。它要吃掉我，我会死的。”
I told him it's just a story. It's just cartoons. Don't be afraid. I told him this is something that's made up. It's not real. I always encouraged him. The ocean is really wonderful. It won't take long. Just two hours, and then you can go to school, and we're going to have a nice house.
我告诉他那只是一个故事。那只是动画片。不要害怕。我告诉他这是编出来的。那不是真的。我总是鼓励他。海洋真的很美妙。不会花很长时间。只要两个小时，然后你就可以上学，我们会有一个漂亮的房子。
But then the first boat that they got on in February was kind of a disaster, and it really affected Hammed. It was supposed to be 35 people in a little rubber boat, but Aziza says that they packed on twice that many and didn't give out life vests. And people wanted to get off, and the smugglers pointed guns at them and said you have to go now. A few people told me stories like that.
但后来他们二月坐的第一艘船是一场灾难，这对哈米德影响很大。那艘小橡皮艇原本应该载 35 人，但阿齐扎说他们硬塞了双倍人数，而且没有分发救生衣。人们想下船，走私者用枪指着他们说你们现在必须走。一些人告诉过我类似的故事。
They got a little ways out, and the boat started to deflate, and started to flip over, just capsized. And people screamed. It was terrifying. No life vests, remember. And Aziza's got a five-year-old, and a seven-year-old, and a nine-year-old with her. And the boat turned back.
他们走出去一点，船开始漏气，开始翻转，直接倾覆了。人们尖叫。那太可怕了。没有救生衣，记得吗。阿齐扎带着一个五岁、一个七岁和一个九岁的孩子。船转了回去。
OK, so after that, how in the world do you get your six kids onto a second boat? That requires some A level parenting moves, and Aziza was the one who had to get her kids onboard, literally onboard in this case. And mainly she painted a picture of the bright future they were going to have in Europe, and she pretended she knew that this new boat was going to be totally different. And they went again.
好的，所以那之后，你到底是怎么把六个孩子弄上第二艘船的？这需要一些顶级的育儿技巧，而阿齐扎是那个必须把孩子们带上船的人，在这种情况下是真正意义上的带上船。主要她描述了一个他们在欧洲将要拥有的光明未来，而且她假装她知道这艘新船会完全不同。他们又去了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yeah, I was afraid more for my kids than for myself. Before we got on  the boat, my son told me, you're the one who is deciding about our lives, whether it's the beginning or the end. And those words really affected me.
是的，我担心孩子比担心自己多。上船前，我儿子对我说，你是在决定我们生命的人，无论是开始还是终结。那些话真的触动了我。
When they got on the boat, she told Hammed, the seven-year-old, to sleep in her arms. He was so terrified he conked out immediately, missed the whole trip. Of course, here in the camp, her husband's with her too. And I asked, does he help with the children? She said, he wasn't any help with that back in Syria, and here, he's totally useless. She tries to get him to handle things, but it's like he's the seventh child that she's taking care of.
他们上船时，她告诉七岁的哈米德睡在她怀里。他太害怕了，立即睡着了，错过了整个旅程。当然，在这里在营地，她丈夫也和她在一起。我问，他帮着照顾孩子了吗？她说，他在叙利亚时在这方面就没帮过忙，而在这里，他完全没用。她试图让他处理事情，但他就像她照顾的第七个孩子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It's had a toll on my mental health seeing my kids and their dad. And we argue a lot about the kids more than anything else. I tell him, you're not helping. You don't talk to the kids. You don't engage them. I always feel like you're detached. He says there's no point in talking to them. You talk to them, and what good has come of it?
看到孩子和他们的爸爸，这对我心理健康造成了损害。而我们争吵最多的就是关于孩子。我告诉他，你没帮忙。你不和孩子交流。你不吸引他们。我总是觉得你很疏离。他说跟他们说话没有意义。你跟他们说话，有什么好结果吗？
They also fight about money. He smokes, a pack or a pack and a half a day. And since they went on the run from Syria, she started smoking too, to deal with the stress, though way less than him, and in secret, so the kids don't see.
他们也因为钱吵架。他抽烟，一天一包或一包半。而自从他们从叙利亚逃亡以来，她也开始抽烟了，为了应对压力，虽然比他少得多，而且偷偷摸摸的，这样孩子们就看不见。
And this is one reason we fight. We're in a situation where we don't need these extra expenses.
这是我们吵架的一个原因。我们处于一种不需要这些额外开支的情况下。
They got on the boat to Greece with 1,000 euros, which was enough for a few weeks on the road. Aziza laughed and said, I think we spent 950 of it on cigarettes.
他们带着 1000 欧元坐船到希腊，这足够在路上待几周了。阿齐扎笑了，说，我想我们把其中 950 欧元都花在香烟上了。
Yeah, I just have 50 euros left.
是的，我只剩下 50 欧元了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
That Arabic expression she just used?
她刚才用的那个阿拉伯语表达？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
My interpreter said that in this context, the best translation for it would be [BLEEP] my life. The other child that Aziza worries about the most is her 18-year-old, Ali. He's a great kid in lots of ways-- very sweet and encouraging with his little brother Hammed. Also he's incredibly skilled at building things for the family.
我的口译员说，在这种语境下，最好的翻译应该是“去他妈的生活”。阿齐扎最担心的另一个孩子是她 18 岁的阿里。他在很多方面都是个好孩子——对他的小弟弟哈米德非常甜心和鼓励。他也非常擅长为家庭建造东西。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
This is all my son's work.
这全是我儿子的作品。
This is Aziza showing us around her sister-in-law's tent, it was nuts. Every family was given a standard issue tent, and they built an outer courtyard with a fence, and there's an overhang so there's shade, and there's a table, and benches, and shelves made from wood that was scavenged from old shipping pallets. And then you go through a door, and there's a kind of mud room pantry with their food, and then another room with a bed for the kids, and shelves with neatly folded children's clothes, and a row of hooks for other clothes.
这是阿齐扎带我们参观她嫂子的帐篷，这太疯狂了。每个家庭都分到了一个标准帐篷，他们建造了一个带围栏的外院，有一个遮阳篷所以有阴凉，还有一张桌子，长椅，货架是用从旧运输托盘上收集的木头做的。然后你穿过一扇门，有一个类似储物间的泥浆房放着他们的食物，然后另一个房间有给孩子们住的床，架子上整齐地叠着儿童衣服，还有一排挂其他衣服的钩子。
And it's all super cheerful. Everything's covered with brightly colored fabric. And then there's another entry, and it's the parents' bedroom with a full size bed and night table. My interpreter, Baraa, later described it the best.
一切都超级欢快。一切都盖着色彩鲜艳的织物。然后还有另一个入口，那是父母的卧室，有一张全尺寸床和床头柜。我的口译员巴拉后来描述得最好。
BARAA: All I could think of was, OK, so you know in Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire, when they all go to the Quidditch World Cup.
巴拉：我能想到的全部就是，好吧，你知道在《哈利波特与火焰杯》里，当他们都去魁地奇世界杯的时候。
Oh, Baraa's 23.
哦，巴拉 23 岁。
BARAA: And then everybody has tents. Everybody's sleeping in tents. But since they're magical tents, from the outside, they look like a regular camping thing. But when you go in, it's so many different rooms. There's a living room. There's a kitchen. So literally walking in, when they opened the door, I swear to God that's what it was like. It was insane what they built. It's crazy.
巴拉：然后每个人都有帐篷。每个人都睡在帐篷里。但因为是魔法帐篷，从外面看，它们看起来像普通的露营装备。但当你走进去，它有这么多不同的房间。有客厅。有厨房。所以走进去时，当他们打开门，我发誓上帝那就是那样的。这太疯狂了，他们建造的东西。太疯狂了。
Ali learned construction from his uncle, but then his aunt says the student became the master. He builds so he doesn't get bored in the camp. But being in the camp has spurred this very good kid into all kinds of behavior he never had before. He started smoking, secretly at first, but now he doesn't bother to hide it, which bothers Aziza. He talks back. He doesn't listen, which is normal for an 18-year-old, but new for him.
阿里从他叔叔那里学到了建筑，但他阿姨说学生变成了大师。他建造东西是为了在营地里不感到无聊。但待在营地里促使这个非常好的孩子有了他以前从来没有过的各种行为。他开始抽烟，起初是偷偷的，但现在他懒得隐藏了，这困扰着阿齐扎。他顶嘴。他不听话，这对于一个 18 岁的人来说很正常，但对他来说是新的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It's like he doesn't care about what I think.
就像他不在乎我怎么想。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I can't tell him what to do anymore. He gets really upset with me, because I promised him, you'll finally be able to relax. You can go to school.
我不能再告诉他做什么了。他真的对我感到愤怒，因为我向他承诺过，你终于可以放松了。你可以去上学。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
You can get the education you were denied in Syria.
你可以得到你在叙利亚被剥夺的教育。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He keeps telling me, this is what you promised us? So this is our future? You made us take the sea and face death, and you brought us here to live like this?
他不停地告诉我，这就是你向我们承诺的吗？所以这就是我们的未来？你让我们下海并面对死亡，你把我们带到这里过这样的生活？
She tells Ali, you can't blame me for what's out of my control. For whatever reason, this is the life that God fated us to live right now. But it's not forever. And a lot of other people are going through the same thing. Ali says, he knows that's true, but it is hard not to get mad. He's got expressive, dark eyes, and a scruffy beard that is more peach fuzz than actual beard.
她告诉阿里，你不能因为我无法控制的事情而责怪我。无论什么原因，这就是上帝注定我们现在要过的生活。但这不会是永远的。还有很多人正在经历同样的事情。阿里说，他知道这是真的，但很难不生气。他有一双生动的深色眼睛，和一点凌乱的胡茬，那是桃绒毛而不是真正的胡子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Because she promised us, she promised us that we'll have a better future in Europe. And now they're fixing the electricity here. That makes me think that we're staying more, and it's really depressing me.
因为她向我们承诺，她承诺我们会在欧洲有更好的未来。现在他们正在这里修理电力。这让我觉得我们待的时间更长了，这真的让我很沮丧。
In fact, just the week I was there, the camp got big outdoor lights, and Wi-Fi, and a proper water supply. Which in a way was just upsetting. The air force colonel who put this camp together told me that they're building the place to last five years for these or other refugees.
事实上，就在我在那里的那一周，营地有了巨大的户外灯、Wi-Fi 和适当的供水系统。这在某种程度上让人不安。那个建立这个营地的空军上校告诉我，他们正在把这个地方建成能维持五年，供这些或其他难民使用。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I was like, what are we going to do here? It's obvious that we're going to stay here for a longer time now. What can I do? I'm doing nothing. I feel that my hands and my legs are just tied, and the days are passing, and passing, and there's nothing. Because of depression and stress, I just think that I'm going to explode sometimes from the situation that I'm living in.
我当时就像，我们在这里要干什么？很明显我们现在要在这里待更长时间。我能做什么？我什么都没做。我感觉我的手和脚都被绑住了，日子一天天过去，过去，什么都没有。因为抑郁和压力，我只是觉得有时我会因为我所处的情况而爆炸。
Mainly, he really, really wants to go to school. He hasn't been in four years. And his 16-year-old brother, Fadi, he's feeling all the same resentments and frustrations he is. And their mom says sometimes the two boys will sleep till 2:00 in the afternoon. And she'll try to wake them, and they get upset with her. And they say, well, why should we get up? We don't have anything to do. We don't have school. We'd rather not wake up and see where we live. We'd rather just sleep.
主要地，他真的、真的很想去上学。他四年没上过学了。而他 16 岁的弟弟法迪，有着和他一样的怨恨和挫败感。他们的妈妈说有时两个男孩会睡到下午 2 点。她会试着叫醒他们，他们会和她闹别扭。他们说，好吧，我们为什么要起来？我们没什么可做的。我们没学校。我们宁愿不起床看看我们住的地方。我们宁愿只睡着。
Aziza says being here in this weird, suspended animation where their lives aren't moving forward at all, where her boys feel like life is passing them by, and they're never going to get to go to school and catch up to where they should be, she told me she is really just at the end of her rope. In Arabic, there's this saying she used, it's like your soul is tired. It's worn out. And she's questioning herself.
阿齐扎说待在这里处于这种奇怪的、悬浮的动画状态，他们的生活根本没有向前发展，她的孩子们觉得生活在从他们身边溜走，他们永远无法去上学赶上他们本该达到的进度，她告诉我她真的已经到了绳子的尽头。在阿拉伯语里，有一个她说过的说法，就像你的灵魂累了。它磨损了。她在质疑自己。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I've done everything I could. I got them here, but it's not in my control to do anything else. I feel like we committed a crime, but I don't know what crime we did.
我尽了我能做的一切。我带他们到了这里，但做其他任何事情都不在我的控制之中。我觉得我们犯了罪，但我不知道我们犯了什么罪。
Sometimes, during these conversations it was hard not to think about how the rest of the world sees Aziza and her family. These are the most hated people in Europe, right? These are the refugees whose possible immigration was a big reason that Britain pulled out of the EU, whose existence has led to the rise of xenophobic parties from Germany to Denmark. These are the Muslims we talk about blocking from our own borders.
有时，在这些谈话中，很难不去想世界其他地方是如何看待阿齐扎和她的家庭的。这些人是欧洲最受憎恨的人，对吧？这些人是难民，他们可能的移民是英国退出欧盟的一个主要原因，他们的存在导致了从德国到丹麦的仇外政党的崛起。这些人是我们谈论阻止进入我们自己边境的穆斯林。
Aziza says she can't go back. Her old house doesn't exist. Her whole family has left Syria. There's nothing for them there. Not long ago, Aziza was missing her own mother, and feeling really sad about that. And the kids noticed, and they told her, we're there for you. And they said, if we could do anything to make you happy, and they tried to cheer her up, and they made  little jokes, and little funny moves, which was really sweet, and she loved it.
阿齐扎说她回不去了。她的老房子不存在了。她整个家庭都离开了叙利亚。那里什么都没有了。不久前，阿齐扎正在想念她自己的母亲，对那感到非常难过。孩子们注意到了，他们告诉她，我们在这里支持你。他们说，如果我们能做任何事情让你开心，他们试图让她振作起来，他们开了小玩笑，做了小小的滑稽动作，那真的非常甜心，她很喜欢。
And they would try to take care of her in the way that she tries to take care of them. At the same time, she felt like, oh, it's come to this? That they're taking care of her? It's like these days when she tells them, they're still going to have a bright future. They just need to hold on. She see's them nod, like they're humoring her, pretending to agree, just to make her feel better. That does not seem good to her, she said. It doesn't seem ideal at all.
他们会试图以她试图照顾他们的方式来照顾她。与此同时，她觉得，哦，到了这个地步？他们照顾她？就像这些天，当她告诉他们，他们仍然会有光明的未来。他们只需要坚持住。她看到他们点头，就像他们在哄她，假装同意，只是为了让她感觉更好。那对她来说看起来一点都不好，她说。那看起来一点都不理想。
Coming up. So for your new life to begin, all you need is for somebody to pick up the phone when you call. And you try, and try again, and try again, and they just do not answer. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
即将到来。所以为了你的新生活开始，你只需要有人在你打电话时接起电话。你尝试，再尝试，又尝试，而他们就是不回答。那就在一分钟后，在节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, are we there yet? Stories of people whose lives are on hold in refugee camps in Greece. So an incredible team has put together an interactive tour of the camps that we visited, with little movies, and photos, and three dimensional architectural renderings created by a group of architects and engineers, Jai Mexis & Partners. Every time they show this to me, I just kind of stare at it and wonder. It's amazing. It's at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，我们到了吗？在希腊难民营中生活搁置的人们的故事。所以一个不可思议的团队制作了一个我们访问过的营地的互动导览，有小电影、照片和由一组建筑师和工程师，Jai Mexis & Partners 创建的三维建筑渲染。每次他们给我看这个，我就盯着它看，感到惊叹。太棒了。在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上。
We've arrived at Act 3 of our program, Act 3. All our representatives are currently busy.
我们已经到达了我们节目的第三幕，第三幕。我们所有的代表目前都在忙。
So the first step for any refugee to leave the refugee camp limbo that they're in in Greece and get relocated elsewhere in Europe, is that they need official asylum papers from Greece. And the problem is, there are too many refugees for the government office that handles this to process quickly. And fearing a situation where just like hundreds of refugees would line up every day at their office door, the asylum office in Greece set up a way for people to make appointments for their interview and their paperwork.
所以任何难民离开他们在希腊所处的难民营困境并重新安置到欧洲其他地方的第一步是，他们需要希腊的官方庇护文件。问题是，难民太多了，政府负责处理此事的办公室无法快速处理。由于担心会出现像成百上千名难民每天排队在办公室门口的情况，希腊的庇护办公室建立了一种人们预约面试和办理文书的方式。
Basically, they set up a system where people could call the office on Skype. And just a word here. If you don't know what Skype is, it's like an internet phone call, like Face Time. People have it on their phones. You can call without the video also. And the asylum office made a schedule of when people could call. So for instance, people who speak Arabic got from 10:00 to noon on Mondays and 10:00 to 11:00 on Tuesdays some weeks. Dari and Farsi speakers got an hour Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
基本上，他们建立了一个系统，人们可以给办公室打 Skype 电话。在这里说明一下。如果你不知道什么是 Skype，它就像互联网电话，就像 FaceTime。人们在手机上有它。你也可以在没有视频的情况下通话。庇护办公室制定了一个人们可以打电话的时间表。所以例如，说阿拉伯语的人在周一有 10:00 到中午，有些周周二有 10:00 到 11:00。达里语和波斯语使用者在周一、周二、周三、周四有一小时。
And making the appointment is important, because once you have the appointment, you get access to health care, and you get a temporary permit to stay in Greece for a year. If you don't have that, they can arrest you. One of our reporters, Miki Meek, went to watch refugees make these Skype calls in Athens. This was six weeks ago.
预约很重要，因为一旦你有了预约，你就可以获得医疗保健，并获得在希腊居住一年的临时许可证。如果你没有那个，他们可以逮捕你。我们的记者之一，米基·米克，去雅典观察难民打这些 Skype 电话。那是六周前的事了。
Turns out, when it comes to pre-registering for asylum, like the cops say on American TV shows, you can do it the easy way, or you can do it the hard way. Here's Miki.
事实证明，当谈到庇护预登记时，就像美国电视节目里的警察所说的那样，你可以选择简单的方式，或者你可以选择困难的方式。这是米基的报告。
Tens of thousands of people were in this weird situation where their entire futures were dependent on getting through on a Skype call, and they were not getting through. So they re-dialed again, and again, and again. People had been stuck doing this for months from their cell phones.
数万人处于这种奇怪的境地，他们整个未来都依赖于打通一个 Skype 电话，而他们就是打不通。所以他们一次又一次地拨号。人们被困在这里，几个月来一直用手机做这件事。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
I've been trying probably more than 500 times.
我已经尝试了大概 500 次以上。
This is Hassan Haidari, 22-years-old, and from Afghanistan. He told me he left after his parents got blown up by a roadside bomb, like they couldn't find remains to bury, like they were evaporated. And he got attacked by the Taliban. Hassan was sitting next to a guy who pulled out his phone to show me his Skype history. His first call to the Greek asylum office was back in March.
这是哈桑·海达里，22 岁，来自阿富汗。他告诉我他在父母被路边炸弹炸死后离开的，就像他们找不到遗体来埋葬，就像他们蒸发了一样。而且他遭到了塔利班的袭击。哈桑坐在一个拿出手机给我看他 Skype 记录的人旁边。他第一次给希腊庇护办公室打电话是在三月。
You're just scrolling through. How many times have you tried to call?
你只是在滚动。你尝试打过多少次电话？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
He says almost 1,000 times. It just says, call, no answer. Call, no answer. Call, no answer. Call failed. And it just keeps going on and on like this. So that's the hard way to do these Skype calls. The easy way, it really isn't much easier. You go to an NGO's office, and you use their Skype account to call in. It's easier because your odds go up.
他说几乎 1000 次。上面只写着，呼叫，无人接听。呼叫，无人接听。呼叫，无人接听。呼叫失败。它就这样一直持续下去。所以这就是打这些 Skype 电话的困难方式。简单的方式，确实也没简单多少。你去一个非政府组织的办公室，用他们的 Skype 账号打进去。这更容易，因为你的几率会上升。
The government asylum office prioritizes calls from NGOs over random Skype callers, which is why Hassan is at the rundown office of an NGO called the Greek Forum of Refugees. He's sitting cross-legged on the ground. It's Wednesday, and Dari speakers like him get an hour, from noon to 1:00, to Skype the asylum office.
政府庇护办公室优先处理来自非政府组织的通话，而不是随机的 Skype 调用者，这就是哈桑在一个叫希腊难民论坛的非政府组织的破旧办公室里的原因。他盘腿坐在地上。今天是周三，像他这样的达里语使用者有一个小时，从中午到 1 点，给庇护办公室打 Skype。
This is someone just coming over to help them start it. Let's see, what time is it right now? All right. So they're trying.
这是有人刚过来帮他们启动。让我们看看，现在几点了？好吧。所以他们在尝试。
[DIALING]
[拨号声]
Hassan's sitting in front of an old laptop with a friend who brought him here, Awaaz. And it's Awaaz who grabs the mouse to reconnect.
哈桑坐在一个旧笔记本电脑前，和他带他到这里的朋友阿瓦兹在一起。是阿瓦兹抓住了鼠标重新连接。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
He says he came to this office over and over for weeks, 15 different times before he finally got through. So he knows the drill. So now they're still trying. So let's see. Let's count how many seconds. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, and it dropped. I mean, does this mean that you spent 15 hours of just letting it ringing and drop?
他说他一次又一次来到这个办公室，持续了几周，15 次不同的尝试后他终于打通了。所以他知道套路。所以现在他们还在尝试。所以让我们看看。让我们数数多少秒。1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9、10，然后它掉了。我是说，这是否意味着你花了 15 个小时只是让它响着然后掉了？
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
Yes, I would keep trying, and keep trying, hoping that the Skype call will go through, and then nothing will happen. Then after a while, you start to feel really desperate.
是的，我会一直尝试，一直尝试，希望 Skype 电话能通，然后什么都不会发生。然后过了一会儿，你开始感到非常绝望。
Hassan says most every Afghan he knows has memorized the Skype schedule for the asylum office.
哈桑说他认识的几乎每个阿富汗人都背下了庇护办公室的 Skype 时间表。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
There are literally thousands of people trying at the same time right now.
现在有成千上万的人在同一时间尝试。
[SKYPE SOUNDS]
[Skype 声音]
That's the sound of it dropping. Re-dialing. Every time their call drops, they scramble for the mouse. It's like playing a very repetitious video game, an incredibly boring one, with very high stakes. 25 deadening minutes pass this way. And then-- you just got through.
那是它掉线的声音。重拨。每次通话掉线，他们就抢鼠标。这就像玩一个非常重复的电子游戏，一个极其无聊的，赌注非常高。25 分钟沉闷的时间就这样过去了。然后——你刚打通了。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
The asylum office picks up. A woman speaks to Hassan through an interpreter. She can see him through the computer camera, but he can't see her. She tells him--
庇护办公室接听了。一名女性通过口译员对哈桑说话。她可以通过电脑摄像头看到他，但他看不见她。她告诉他——
Sit back straight.
坐直了。
Then she takes this photo, and starts to put together his file.
然后她拍下这张照片，开始整理他的档案。
What your name?
你叫什么名字？
She takes down all his bio information, then tells him to write down five numbers.
她记下他所有的个人资料信息，然后告诉他写下五个数字。
Please, write down this code. 18-572. That's your registration number.
请写下这个代码。18-572。那是你的注册号码。
Hassan's appointment at the asylum office would be in three weeks.
哈桑在庇护办公室的预约将在三周后。
All right. Thank you. Bye.
好的。谢谢。再见。
Wait, sit down. Come here.
等一下，坐下。过来。
I'm very, very happy. I'm very happy.
我非常、非常高兴。我非常高兴。
Hassan jumps out of his chair, and pumps his fists in the air. Awaaz is smiling in disbelief.
哈桑从椅子上跳起来，在空中挥动拳头。阿瓦兹难以置信地笑着。
It's crazy that I've coming here for 15 days. I cried so much. And he's so lucky. He just got it on the first day.
我来这里 15 天真是太疯狂了。我哭得太多了。而且他太幸运了。他在第一天就打通了。
Hassan reaches over, and grabs Awaaz by the chin.
哈桑伸手抓住阿瓦兹的下巴。
I feel like-- my friend, I'm so-- I like this guy a lot. I want to kiss him on the cheek and thank him for bringing me here, and just because it just worked on the first day, on the first call.
我觉得——我的朋友，我太——我非常喜欢这个家伙。我想亲他的脸颊，感谢他带我到这里，只是因为它在第一天，第一次呼叫就通了。
I mean, you should go for it. Just kiss him on the cheek.
我是说，你应该去做。去亲他的脸颊。
[SPEAKING DARI]
[达里语交谈]
[KISSING SOUND]
[亲吻声]
He just patted his head. At 1 o'clock, the Afghans leave, and the Syrians arrive. There are so many more Syrian refugees in Greece that they get two hours, not one. And they occupy every available space outside the office door. Kids sleep on garbage bags their parents have placed on the floor. Men sit shoulder to shoulder in the stairwell. That's what the Skype app sounds like when a roomful of people have it on speakerphone.
他只是拍了拍他的头。在 1 点，阿富汗人离开了，叙利亚人到了。希腊有太多的叙利亚难民，他们有两小时，而不是一小时。他们占据了办公室门外的所有可用空间。孩子们睡在父母放在地板上的垃圾袋上。男人们在楼梯间肩并肩坐着。这就是当一屋子人把 Skype 设为免提时听到的声音。
A guy named Mohammed Al Shahani holds his phone out to show me. Mohammed's 21 years old. He's from a bombed out city in northern Syria called Idlib.
一个叫穆罕默德·阿尔·沙哈尼的人拿着他的手机给我看。穆罕默德 21 岁。他来自叙利亚北部一个被炸毁的城市叫伊德利卜。
That sound, it must drive you crazy.
那个声音，它一定让你发疯。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I hear it all the time. It's ingrained in my brain, the Skype ring tone over and over again.
我一直听到它。它已经深深烙印在我的大脑里，Skype 铃声一次又一次地响起。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I mean, we hear it while we're sleeping. It just plays and plays, even in your dreams.
我是说，我们睡觉时都能听到。它只是在播放，甚至在你的梦里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
But we're still hoping for the best. God willing, we'll get through.
但我们仍然希望能有最好的结果。上帝保佑，我们会打通的。
He's here at the office with his family-- mom, dad, and siblings. There are eight of them in total. They're living in tents they've pitched on pavement at a cruise ship terminal. It takes an hour and a half to get here.
他和他家人来到这里——妈妈、爸爸和兄弟姐妹。总共八个人。他们住在他们在邮轮码头的人行道上搭起的帐篷里。到这里要花一个半小时。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I feel like if we don't-- if nobody picks up today, we're just going to be done. We're not coming back. Because it's so hard for us to come. We have young kids, and we have our wives with us. And just for us to get here, you have to take a train, and then you walk 10 kilometers.
我觉得如果没人——如果今天没人接听，我们就要结束了。我们不来了。因为我们来这里太难了。我们有年幼的孩子，有妻子和我们在一起。仅仅是我们来到这里，你必须坐火车，然后你走 10 公里。
Mohammad's serious. He's done with these Skype sessions, which will not go down so well with his dad, Rajab. It's his dad who's made everyone start walking at 6:00 AM three times a week for the past three months. He wants to make sure they're first in line to use the laptop. Because if they're not, they'll probably sit in the hallway the whole time and never get on. But all this has made things pretty tense. Here's Rajab.
穆罕默德是认真的。他受够了这些 Skype 会话，他父亲拉贾布对此可不太高兴。是他父亲让每个人在过去三个月里每周三次在早上 6 点开始走路。他想确保他们是第一批使用笔记本电脑的人。因为如果他们不是，他们可能会整段时间坐在走廊里永远也打不通。但所有这一切让情况变得相当紧张。这是拉贾布。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Because they're so tired of coming every day, you know? We come, and we go. We keep going back and forth. They're so tired. They're tired of it.
因为他们每天来这里太累了，你知道吗？我们来了，我们走。我们不断地来回走。他们太累了。他们厌倦了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
This is it. This is all we do. That's it. I live my life based on these time slots.
就是这样。这就是我们要做的全部。就是这样。我根据这些时间段过我的生活。
OK, so just it just dropped again. We gotta call again? Hold on. The theory in this office is that it takes so long to get through because there aren't that many operators answering the Skype calls.
好的，它又掉了。我们还得再打？等一下。这个办公室的理论是，之所以打通需要这么久，是因为没有多少操作员在接听 Skype 电话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
An NGO employee next to Rajab says it might be just one or two. He's been sitting in on these calls for months. I didn't believe that could possibly be true. One or two people for all the thousands of Syrians needing asylum appointments? Then Joanna, the NPR reporter we worked with on the show, went and visited the asylum office.
拉贾布旁边的一名非政府组织员工说可能只有一两个。他已经在这些通话中坐了几个月了。我不相信那是真的。所有人成千上万需要庇护预约的叙利亚人只有一两个人在接听？然后我们节目中合作的 NPR 记者乔安娜，去访问了庇护办公室。
It does sound incredible. The asylum office has over 350 employees, and this is the biggest thing they're working on. But it's true. The number of people manning the Skype line for all of Greece is exactly one. Her name is Katerina Maliotaki, lifetime civil servant, a big personality with black hair she's dyed bright red. She keeps a stuffed Kermit the Frog doll next to her computer that she squeezes when she gets stressed.
听起来确实令人难以置信。庇护办公室有超过 350 名员工，这是他们正在处理的最大的一件事。但这是真的。负责整个希腊 Skype 专线的人数正好是一个。她的名字叫卡特琳娜·马里奥塔基，终身公务员，个性十足，有着染成亮红色的黑发。她电脑旁边放着一个填充科米蛙玩偶，她在压力大时会捏它。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Hello, sir. How are you? Good morning. What country are you from? Great. Thank you.
你好，先生。你好吗？早上好。你是哪个国家的？太好了。谢谢。
Katerina sits in a tiny, little office where she can barely move, with an interpreter that's right next to her.
卡特琳娜坐在一个微小的、小小的办公室里，几乎无法移动，旁边就有一个口译员。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
I take one call after another without leaving even half a minute gap in between. Without taking a breath, my hand automatically grabs the mouse. We can't waste any time, because as we know, there are tens of thousands of refugees. Everyone is waiting on you to answer the call, and you know that you can't possibly answer all of them.
我接连不断的通话，中间甚至没留下半分钟的间隙。没喘口气，我的手自动抓住鼠标。我们不能浪费任何时间，因为我们知道，有成千上万的难民。每个人都在等你接听电话，而且你知道你不可能接听所有人的电话。
She picks up a call from a Syrian woman. She's in a little square on the right hand side of the screen, wearing a peach headscarf.
她接起了一个叙利亚女性的电话。她在屏幕右侧的一个小方框里，戴着桃色头巾。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
She tells her hello. Every time Katerina answers a call, she sits up straight and smiles, even though the refugees can't see her from their end.
她向她打招呼。卡特琳娜每次接听电话时，都会坐直并微笑，尽管难民们从他们那一端看不见她。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
She tells her to look at the camera. Bravo. Wonderful. Thank you. The entire time she's processing the woman and her kids, the left side of Katerina's screen is filling up with a long line of flashing calls. Katerina estimates in a regular workday, with calls in Farsi, Dari, French, Arabic, English, she'll only register about 100 people, maybe 12 an hour. That's the best she can do.
她告诉她看镜头。太棒了。极好。谢谢。当她在处理这个女性和她的孩子们时，卡特琳娜屏幕的左侧正被长长的闪烁通话线路填满。卡特琳娜估计在一个正常的工作日，通话语言有波斯语、达里语、法语、阿拉伯语、英语，她只能注册大约 100 人，每小时也许 12 人。那是她能做的最好情况了。
So why is she the only one doing this job? Well, Greece is broke. The entire government has been on austerity for six years. There's no money to hire anyone else, and this agency is just three years old. It was never meant to handle such a big workload. The director told me they'd need to hire more than 1,000 people just to keep up.
那么为什么只有她在做这项工作？好吧，希腊破产了。整个政府已经紧缩了六年。没有钱雇佣其他人，而且这个机构才三岁。它从来没有打算处理这么大的工作量。主任告诉我，他们需要雇佣 1000 多人才能跟上进度。
She said, sure, they could move more people to taking Skype calls, but that would just cut the number of people processing asylum applications. One way or another, it's going to be very, very slow. Katerina says sometimes refugees yell at her when she finally picks up their call. They want to know, why have I been calling for months?
她说，当然，他们可以调更多人来接听 Skype 电话，但这只会减少处理庇护申请的人数。无论如何，这都会非常、非常慢。卡特琳娜说有时难民在终于接通他们的电话时会对她大喊大叫。他们想知道，为什么我已经打了几个月的电话？
I mean, what's it like knowing that thousands of people are trying to reach you, and you can only pick up a few calls at a time?
我是说，知道成千上万的人正试图联系你，而你一次只能接听几个电话，那是什么感觉？
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
It feels heavy and worrisome for us. Because you do as much as you can, with all of your heart, your strength, your expertise. But whatever you do, even in doing your best, will always be just a drop in the ocean. So this big disappointment does come over us. Because no one is satisfied.
这对我们来说感觉沉重且令人担忧。因为你用你的心、你的力量、你的专业知识尽你所能。但无论你做什么，即使尽了最大努力，永远也只是大海里的一滴水。所以这种巨大的失望确实笼罩着我们。因为没有人感到满意。
Katerina told me she read a news article about a Syrian man who dreamed all night about Skype. She switches to English to explain.
卡特琳娜告诉我她读过一篇关于叙利亚男人的新闻文章，他整晚都梦见 Skype。她切换到英语解释。
He was saying that every night he's dreaming. I'm trying to sleep, and I see in my dreams that I'm calling on Skype. And really, I wanted to tell him that, oh my friend, I have the same problem. Really.
他说他每晚都在做梦。我试图睡觉，我看到在梦里我在 Skype 上打电话。真的，我想告诉他，噢，我的朋友，我有同样的问题。真的。
So we're back at the NGO office. It's 3:55. The session ends at 4:00. My interpreter and I are the only ones in the room who feel any suspense about whether the people here will get through. Rajab, the dad who dragged his whole family here, he just looks tired. He sits on a plastic lawn chair, staring at the computer screen. Hassan Mohammed, who told me if you don't get through today, he's never coming back, he's off in the waiting room, robotically re-dialing on Skype.
所以我们回到非政府组织办公室。现在是 3:55。会话在 4:00 结束。我的口译员和我是房间里唯一感到悬念的人，看这里的人是否能打通。拉贾布，那个拉着全家来这里的爸爸，他看起来只是累了。他坐在塑料草坪椅上，盯着电脑屏幕。哈桑·穆罕默德，那个告诉我如果你今天打不通，他永远不会再来的人，他在候车室，机械地在 Skype 上重拨。
Hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry. Two more minutes. Two more minutes.
快、快、快、快。还有两分钟。还有两分钟。
An NGO employee says to no one in particular, "moment of silence for the lost souls on Skype about to die." They haven't picked up. The time's up.
一名非政府组织员工对谁也没特别指地说，“为 Skype 上那些即将死去的迷失灵魂默哀”。他们没接。时间到了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I mean, that's it. We're done for the day. I mean, we're done.
我是说，就是这样。我们今天结束了。我是说，我们结束了。
I leave the room to check in with Rajab's son, Mohammed, who's still out in the now empty hallway.
我离开房间去查看拉贾布的儿子穆罕默德，他还在现在空荡荡的走廊里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The entire time from 2:00 to 4:00, there is hope. Everybody's still holding on. No one wants to go on. But once that clock strikes 4:00, that's when everybody leaves. They literally, they hate everything. They hate themselves. They hate this world. They hate their kids. Like, they hate everything.
从 2 点到 4 点，每个人都怀有希望。每个人仍然在坚持。没人想走。但一旦时钟敲响 4 点，那就是每个人离开的时候。他们真的，他们讨厌一切。他们讨厌自己。他们讨厌这个世界。他们讨厌他们的孩子。就像，他们讨厌一切。
Does your dad know that you're not going to come back?
你爸爸知道你不会再来了吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
No, no. He doesn't. He doesn't know I don't want to come back.
不，不。他不知道。他不知道我不想再来了。
When are you going to tell your dad? Are you going to tell him today, or are you going to wait until he comes back for an appointment next week that you're not coming?
你打算什么时候告诉爸爸？你是打算今天告诉他，还是你打算等到他下周回来参加预约而你不来时才告诉他？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
No, I'm not going to tell him at all.
不，我根本不会告诉他。
Not going to show up next week?
下周不打算出现？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I can't keep coming back. I'm done. That's it. I just want to go back to Syria. I just want to-- I just want to leave and smuggle myself back to Syria. I don't want to tell him.
我不能一直回来。我受够了。就是这样。我只想回叙利亚。我只是想——我只是想离开并把自己偷渡回叙利亚。我不想告诉他。
He didn't go back to Syria. The next week, he got up, started walking to the train station at 6:00 AM, and came back to the office early enough to be first in line again.
他没回叙利亚。下周，他起床，在早上 6 点开始走到火车站，并足够早地回到办公室，再次成为第一排。
Miki Meek. So because those Skype calls have been criticized, in the time since Miki recorded those people who were calling in, the United Nations Refugee Agency, UNHCR, has started going to camps with the Greek government to pre-register hundreds of people at a time in person, so they don't have to use Skype. And they've done tons of people this way, over 25,000 people.
米基·米克。所以因为那些 Skype 电话受到了批评，在米基记录那些正在打电话的人之后，联合国难民署，UNHCR，已经开始和希腊政府一起到营地当面预登记数百人，这样他们就不必使用 Skype 了。他们以这种方式处理了很多人，超过 25,000 人。
But the problem is, these people were told when they do this, OK, you're pre-registered for asylum, but they weren't given an actual appointment. Like, they weren't given a date to come in to be interviewed and start the asylum process. An NGO staffer told us that the government tells the refugees that they'll be texted sometime in the coming year with a date. And then after that, the asylum process itself, that they're just applying for, right? That itself can take months.
但问题是，这些人在这样做时被告知，好吧，你已经预登记了庇护，但他们没拿到实际的预约。就像，没给他们日期来面试并开始庇护程序。一名非政府组织员工告诉我们，政府告诉难民他们将在接下来的这一年里收到短信告知日期。然后在那之后，庇护程序本身，他们只是在申请，对吧？那本身就需要几个月。
But that's just the delay that all these people face with the local bureaucracy in Greece. The next problem they have is, although the rest of Europe has officially agreed to let in these 57,000 people into their countries, they're not doing it. Only 2,681 have been relocated out of 57,000. It's totally stalled. Apparently, the politics for any country to allow in refugees right now is too delicate to let these people in.
但那只是所有这些人面对希腊当地官僚机构的拖延。他们的下一个问题是，尽管欧洲其他国家已经正式同意接收这 57,000 人进入他们的国家，但他们并没这样做。在 57,000 人中，只有 2,681 人被安置出来。完全停滞了。显然，现在任何国家允许难民进入的政治都太微妙了，无法让这些人进来。
Dimitris Vitsas, who's in charge of coordinating the refugee crisis in Greece, he's the Deputy Ministry of Defense, he told me that Greece understands that these 57,000 people may not be going anywhere for a very long time. And when they finally do leave, given the situation in the world, others are probably going to show up to replace them.
迪米特里斯·维萨斯，负责协调希腊难民危机的人，他是国防部副部长，他告诉我希腊明白这 57,000 人可能很久很久都不会去任何地方。而且当他们最终离开时，鉴于世界的情况，其他人很可能会出现取代他们。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Our goal is to have ready over 60,000 places where we can host refugees and migrants in central Greece--
我们的目标是在希腊中部准备好 60,000 多个地方，我们可以用来托管难民和移民——
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Indefinitely moving forward for the coming years.
在未来的几年里无限期地向前推进。
Indefinitely. Now, short term, they hope to get 2/3 of the refugees, 40,000 people, out of tents and into little trailers that they call "iso boxes," which have AC, and heat, and proper kitchens, and showers, and bathrooms. And they hope to do that by September, or anyway before winter. They have money for this provided by the rest of Europe.
无限期。现在，短期内，他们希望 2/3 的难民，40,000 人，从帐篷里搬出来，进入他们称之为“iso boxes”的小拖车里，这些拖车有空调、暖气、合适的厨房、淋浴间和卫生间。他们希望在九月前，或者无论如何要在冬天前做到这一点。他们为此有欧洲其他地方提供的资金。
The other roughly 20,000 refugees--
另外大约 20,000 名难民——
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Our goal is to have 20,000 people in houses and apartments by the end of September.
我们的目标是在九月底前让 20,000 人住进房子和公寓。
This is not only better for the refugees than living in the camps, it's great for the Greeks, because it puts money into the hands of Greek citizens. Basically, other European countries will pay Greek property owners to fix up and rent out rooms, and apartments, and houses to the refugees. The Greeks are also hoping to set up schools for refugee children by the end of September. I did talk to officials from the International Rescue Committee and UNHCR, and they applauded these ambitions, but they were deeply skeptical that Greece would actually make the goals for such large numbers of refugees.
这不仅对生活在营地里的难民更好，对希腊人来说也很好，因为它把钱放进了希腊公民的手里。基本上，其他欧洲国家将支付希腊业主修理房间、公寓和房屋并租给难民的费用。希腊人也希望在九月底前为难民儿童设立学校。我确实和来自国际救援委员会和联合国难民署的官员谈过，他们对这些抱负表示赞赏，但他们深表怀疑希腊是否真的能实现如此多难民的目标。
But this whole plan that Greece is preparing for tens of thousands of refugees to be there for a long, long time? The refugees don't know it. People we met in the camps really had no idea, and they're trying to move ahead with parts of their lives, whatever they can. And in fact, next week on our show, we have stories of people trying to do that, like this couple that met and fell in love, even though they were not expecting anything like that to happen to them while en route from one country to another. And even though her family did not approve and tried to keep them apart, the guy in the couple was undeterred.
但希腊准备的整个 tens of thousands 难民待很长很长一段时间的计划？难民们不知道。我们在营地遇见的人确实根本不知道，他们正试图推进他们生活的部分，无论他们能做什么。事实上，下周我们的节目，我们有试图做那件事的人们的故事，就像这对相遇并坠入爱河的夫妇，即使他们并没有预料到在从一个国家前往另一个国家的途中会发生那样的事情。即使她的家庭不赞同并试图拆散他们，这对夫妇里的家伙并没有被吓倒。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I love her very much, and those people won't stand in our way. And our love is stronger than this country that's blocking the border.
我非常爱她，那些人不会挡住我们的路。我们的爱比这个阻挡边境的国家更强大。
That's next week on our program.
那是下周我们的节目。
[MUSIC - THE GORIES, "STRANDED"]
[音乐 - The Gories, "Stranded"]